Ngày hai mấy thứ thống môi, ông Kirin Dimitriën,
là phải biến của tổng thúng á,
bệnh mẹ Putin về đầu tư và hợp tắc của tế.
Trò biết, ngà, Mỹ, vũ quay nâng tiến gần,
tổng vừa giải pháp ngoại gào nhằm chấm rất cuộc sông đột kéo dài,
đả hơn, bà nằm dợi qua.
Quay gà phát biểu với căn chú thấyng CNN,
sau khi đến Washington, để gặp dơ chức Mỹ, ông Dimitriën khẳng định,
của gặp thượng định dưới tổng thống Putin và tổng thống Trump,
chưa bị quyền hoàn toàn mà chỉ tà mọi anh cho đến thời điểm phu hợp.
Ông nhân định việc tổng thống của quay nâng của lúc đi miệng CNN,
tể hiện lập trường sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn
giọc theo các đường trên đường hiện nay là một tiền hiểu thích cửc mở đường cho đối thoại.
Theo trên thống Mỹ, ông Dimitriën dự kiến sẽ gặp đặt phải biến Mỹ về Trung Đông,
Steve Piddcock, tại thành phố Miami, Bằng Sòi Đà, Bằng ngày Hamilam Thống Bười.
Chứ cho đi ông nhân mạnh sẽ nói ra ổ lập trường của Mascava về tiền hoa đam.
Với người đồng cấp Mỹ, nông thời giao buộc anh và cho ông đang tạo áp lực buộc kiét,
rưỡi chỉ của sung đột. Truyền thăm Mỹ của ông Dimitriën dễn ra chỉ hành ngày sau khi tổng thủ đúng nân Trump,
ác đặt trường phát hai tập đoàn dầu khi lớn nhất của Ngà, La Russ Net và Lu Koi.
Nhằm người xưa kép buộc Mascava chấm dứt chiến sử,
tuy nhiên ông Dimitriën cạnh báo, các lần trường phát có thể phản thắng giúp khiến ra xong rầu tại Mỹ tâm mạnh,
đông thời khẳng đec đối thoại giữa hai nước chỉ của thiện ra, nếu lợi ít của Ngà được tổ hiểu và tốn trọng.